[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
the accused highland park shooter makes
his first court appearance two days
after the deadly fourth of july shooting
and and that wound
goes across his throat and angles
downward
miss frank planned for mr sessions to
come to her residence that evening
attorneys present opening statements in
the double murder trial for accused
killer kevin eastman plus
body camera footage shows what led up to
the killing of jalen walker and later a
wisconsin woman accused of decapitating
her lover will soon head to trial we
enter not guilty pleas at once law and
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckman the accused
highland park illinois shooter is
officially charged with seven counts of
first-degree murder as officials reveal
he seriously contemplated another attack
in wisconsin's capital city
seven people were killed and dozens of
others injured when the 21 year old
allegedly opened fire at a fourth of
july celebration outside of chicago
investigators say the alleged gunman
dressed as a woman to blend in before
shooting at the crowd from a rooftop the
suspect appeared for his first court
appearance wednesday morning where he
showed no emotion as prosecutors read
out victims names officials say he
admitted to the shooting and is now
being held without bond at a press
conference following the hearing
investigators say the suspect carried
out the attack in illinois then drove
north to wisconsin where he contemplated
performing another shooting in madison
bringing along 60 rounds of ammunition
he later returned to illinois and was
arrested the suspect's parents have
since retained attorney steve greenberg
known for representing r kelly they
released a statement saying in part
quote our hearts thoughts and prayers go
out to everybody all this comes as
investigators say the suspect slipped
past illinois red flag safeguards
according to reports police responded to
a call in 2019 that the suspect was
quote going to kill everyone there they
confiscated 16 knives including a dagger
and a sword from the suspect's home
years later the alleged gunman was still
able to legally purchase the weapon used
in the attack
joining us today is legal analyst dr
tracy pearson and co-host terry austin
dr pearson we're learning more details
of the highland park shooter daily but
no motive yet what possible motives do
you see based on what we've learned so
far
what we know is that he has had a couple
run-ins with law enforcement in one
situation it was because he had
attempted suicide so i think that one
possible motive here could have been
that he was attempting to uh
go out in a in a stream of chaos
sometimes folks who engage in this sort
of behavior um are are first of all
they're angry obviously but but they are
attempting to go out as um i don't want
to say heroes but famous or infamous and
in this situation that very well could
be the case given that he was looking at
another uh possible mass shooting after
the one that he committed in illinois
yeah unfortunately death by cop is or
suicide by a cop as some call it is a a
tactic that some people employ uh
horrible for our parties involved terry
the death penalty was abolishing
illinois in 2011 but in 2018 there were
calls to bring him back specifically for
cop killers do you think this could
reignite that conversation in illinois
well you know it's possible brian i
think the act of killing a police
officer is particularly heinous and i
think in 2018 when former governor bruce
rauner talked about it it was because
that is such a heinous crime but here i
think you could also call back the death
penalty because of the number of people
who were killed most states that have
the death penalty list certain types of
crimes that would call for capital
punishment and having multiple victims
is definitely one of them killing a
police officer is one of them killing
someone if you are imprisoned is another
reason so i do think that the discussion
of the death penalty is something that
could be timely considering this
horrible mass shooting and in other
states also frankly where we have mass
shootings so it's possible
yeah i mean just the numbers of mass
shootings it's it's only july and i
think it's something around 300 in the
country i bet a lot of states are
probably reconsidering just what you're
talking about terry well a verdict is
handed down in the california trial of
eric holder the man facing murder
charges for the death of rapper nipsey
hussell thirty-three-year-old nipsy
hussle was shot and killed in march of
2019 in front of the rapper's marathon
clothing store in los angeles after
three years of delays his accused killer
eric holder jr face a jury trial on
charges of first degree murder attempted
murder and assault with a deadly weapon
holder allegedly shot nipsy hustle after
a dispute between the two men police say
he accused holder of being a snitch a
medical examiner found the rapper was
shot at least 10 times with the bullets
piercing his lungs and severing his
spinal cord on wednesday afternoon
jurors announced their verdict finding
holder junior guilty of first-degree
murder attorneys presented closing
arguments last week arguing their final
plea to the jury as they entered
deliberations prosecutors said the
killing was planned by holder junior
while holder's defense attorney argued
the shooting was not premeditated at all
as i told you in my opening statement i
was very upfront i told you where we're
going and what i would like you to look
for
we told you that mr holder jr did shoot
mr ascadon and accidentally shoot mr
latham and grace uh mr villanueva
but that it was not first degree
murder and it was not first degree
attempted murder against the civilian
away but in this election
we told you that was voluntary
manslaughter and that he acted
in a heat of passion
we told you what that need of passion
that he acted under consisted of
it consisted of being called publicly a
snitch
by someone as famous as nixie hustle
and we believe that that is what the
evidence
still ahead on law and crime daily ohio
officials released body cam footage
showing what led up to the police
shooting of jalen walker but first a
double murder prosecutor said it was
part of a love triangle opening
statements are presented in the colorado
trial of kevin eastman
[Music]
welcome back attorneys present opening
statements in the colorado double murder
trial of kevin dean eastman a man
accused of killing his ex-girlfriend and
her lover eastman is charged with two
counts of first-degree murder tampering
with a deceased human body tampering
with physical evidence and possession of
a weapon by a previous offender that
last charge will be tried in a separate
trial following the verdict on the more
serious charges
authorities say eastman killed his
ex-girlfriend heather frank and local
greeley colorado musician stanley scott
sessions on separate days in february of
2020 and what prosecutors say appears to
have been a love triangle eastman
previously told investigators he went to
frank's apartment to talk about getting
back together but she told him to leave
because she had a date at a preliminary
hearing months after the deaths
prosecutors called the throat-slitting
killing of sessions on ambush and that
eastman family shot frank to silence the
only witness to sessions murder before
frank's body was found she and eastman
both had arrest warrants for sessions
murder investigators say eastman also
burned session's body and allegedly was
preparing to burn frank's body when law
enforcement arrested him at a gas
station in opening statements tuesday
prosecutors laid out the case for the
state describing the brutal death of
scott sessions
you're going to hear
from a forensic pathologist
who
um
who did the autopsy
on
um
on the defen on um scott sessions and
you're gonna hear
that the pathologist will tell you
that there is a very
horrific
terrible
violent
shark
and that bloom
goes across his throat and angles
downward
and it was
done with such
force
that
it goes almost
it goes all the way to the spinal column
and it suffers
an eastman's defense attorney presented
their opening statement tuesday pointing
the finger at frank being responsible
for sessions death
miss frank planned for mr sessions to
come to her residence that evening
miss frank initiated
mr sessions to hurry up and come over
and miss frank was the one who waited
for mr sessions to come over when mr
sessions body was located at pingree
park
it had been carried from a vehicle to
the location where it was found by a
downed tree and his head was covered in
a blue cloth that had been wrapped over
plastic and secured
by gray duct tape
and when investigators were president at
the autopsy they did a very careful job
of collecting that duct tape
and the reason for that was they wanted
to know
who was it that wrapped mr sessions head
and duct tape before his body was burned
and the dna on that duct tape
was his rights
terry what was the strongest part of the
prosecution's opening aside from her
taking a sip of her drink midway that
made you think yeah eastman's guilty
you know it's interesting when you
listen to prosecution's opening
oftentimes you feel like well i think
the defendant must be guilty and here
that's the first thing you think about
as well there is an abundance of
physical evidence first of all you heard
her talking about the slit to the throat
that it was done so forcibly that it
went back to the spine that shows some
personal anger and that means that the
motive of a you know triangle here a
love triangle probably is the case and
also as far as the ex-girlfriend is
concerned heather frank the gun is the
weapon here that was used and the fact
that all of the bullets weren't used and
they found some of the extra bullets
with eastman so i do think there is an
abundance of physical evidence and also
including the phone evidence where they
have the telephone locations together so
i do think it's a strong prosecution
opening we'll see what the defense has
to do with that no doctor you had such a
great point about this we actually had
to scrap the question that i put and i
want to ask you this after the defense's
opening statements did you get the sense
that they were pointing the finger at
another suspect
i did they didn't do it directly but
they certainly were alluding to it
there was a former employer of mr
eastmans who uh at whose property uh mr
eastman was staying and um there's a box
of bullets there that may match the
bullets that were used in this in this
alleged crime um however they don't
match the bullets that were found on mr
eastman according to defense they're
saying that they're going to
be presenting some experts about that
additionally um the defense talked about
the fact that the uh that there was
somebody observed burning something up
near a river but it wasn't mr eastman
mr eastman's body
looks completely different than the
person they observed so i think there's
very strong possibility that there could
be another suspect out there well it
seems like the seed is planted let's see
how that grows in colorado as his case
continues i think you might be getting a
call from a colorado defense attorney
though doctor but please stay with us
coming up on law and crime daily a
wisconsin woman pled not guilty to the
murder and dismemberment of her one-time
lover plus body camera footage reveals
more details in the deadly shooting of
25 year old jalen walker
[Music]
welcome back disturbing body camera
footage shows what led up to the
shooting death of 25 year old jalen
walker a black man who was shot and
killed by police officers it happened on
june 27 in akron ohio when officers
pulled walker over for a traffic
violation body camera footage shows a
foot chase as officers reported a weapon
was discharged out of walker's vehicle
according to a release from the akron
police department the officers believe
walker
posed a deadly threat to them after that
they opened fire he was pronounced dead
at the scene later reports show there
was a weapon in walker's vehicle but it
was not on him when he was shot he had
no prior criminal history newly released
body camera footage shows what led up to
the shooting and how officers responded
to the scene
he's slowing down here slowing down
[Music]
at a press conference over the weekend
akron's police chief confirmed walker
was shot more than 60 times
a lot of rounds were fired and i will
not be surprised if the number at the
end of the investigation is consistent
with the number that has been
circulating in the media but right now
we just don't know while bci needs to
confirm the number of number of times mr
walker was shot the emmys report
indicates over 60 wounds to mr walker's
body
however they are still working to
determine entrance and exit wounds
and this investigation on their end will
take time
it will take time for them to determine
how many times mr walker was actually
shot
all eight officers involved in the
shooting are now on administrative leave
the death is now being investigated by
the ohio bureau of criminal
investigations
terry 60 bullet wounds or maybe more
that seems to be the most jarring issue
in this police shooting and how many of
those shots were when walker was already
on the ground could this be the issue
for if criminal or civil charges are
filed
well brian from a criminal perspective
the issue is whether this was a
reasonable use of force and according to
the akron police procedures deadly force
can be used if those officers reasonably
perceived an immediate threat to safety
either their safety or the safety of
others and they can use that force until
the threat no longer exists so the
number of bullets is an interesting
question when was that threat ceased and
one of the things they're going to look
at from a criminal perspective is that
department of transportation camera and
the radio communication talking about a
flash from the car those police officers
might argue that they thought there was
a gun and that he had a gun from a civil
perspective it's less of a burden to
prove that perhaps there was a violation
of walker's constitutional rights and so
i do expect regardless of what happens
with the criminal side we could very
well see that civil charges might be
brought and ultimately there might be a
settlement in the case yeah well dr
pearson terry listed some of them but
these are some of the arguments i can
see the police making they're going to
point to the fact that a
shot was reported coming from the car
that a gun was found in a very
precocious uh way in fact and that
tasers didn't work but is there room for
reform that 90 bullets were fired is
excessive when taking down an unarmed
suspect
i think that we need to find a way to
make that excessive i i think that this
was unconscionable
and we often see in these situations
sort of a group think or group response
so in this situation it felt like it one
officer fired and then everyone else
joined in and in that situation that
that's that becomes thuggery if they're
not wearing a badge in this situation uh
we're looking at you know an officer who
officers who may have been at risk
though as you said precocious the the
gun was actually noted on the
pre-autopsy report in the back seat of
the car and when uh later on was
reported as being in the front seat
stayed possibly staged with a with um a
ring and some some uh ammunition so i i
i think we need to do something but it
becomes difficult to legislate how many
bullets makes makes sense in that
situation absolutely we'll see how that
continues when we come back prosecutors
say she murdered and dismembered her
lover we had we had to wisconsin where
taylorship business will soon stand
trial
[Music]
welcome back a wisconsin woman accused
of murdering and decapitating her lover
is now headed to trial after pleading
not guilty on all charges 24 year old
taylorship business was arrested back in
february in connection to the murder of
25 year old chad thyrion
investigators in green bay wisconsin
station business quote went crazy and
choked tyrion to death during sex after
that she decapitated him and dismembered
his body the case made national
headlines when news broke that tyrion's
mother found his decapitated head in a
bucket at the bottom of his stairs
investigators later found pieces of
tyrion's body and should business's
vehicle after a series of hearings she
business was ruled competent to stand
trial earlier this year at a hearing on
tuesday she pled not guilty to charges
of first-degree murder and mutilating a
corpse
mr jolly of you and your client received
a copy of the information yes your honor
are you asking that the information be
read out formally in open court no your
honor will wave the
reading of the information i've gone
over with my client it does appear to
mirror what is in the complaint we enter
not guilty please and on calls
right now your business is being held on
a two million dollar bond a trial date
is set for october of this year dr
pearson so this defense is often thought
of but maybe not always argued but when
a defense attorney hears strangled
during sex we have to ask
do you think death by erotic
asphyxiation is a potential defense here
potential
but not viable
when we're looking at that defense we're
thinking it was an accident
unfortunately the defendant's statements
in this case suggest otherwise she saw
that the victim was struggling and she
also admitted to
voluntary drug use which i think doesn't
support that defense but you can always
try yeah hey i was high i thought he was
enjoying it couldn't control myself i
don't know we'll see how it plays out
there's an accident but there's also the
insanity defense should business
allegedly told authorities she blacked
out is that a potential defense here too
you know i think she could use that as a
potential defense brian you know under
wisconsin law like a lot of states a
person is not responsible for that
criminal conduct if at the time of that
conduct and as a result of the mental
illness or mental disease or mental
defect they lack substantial capacity to
appreciate the wrongfulness and if she
blacked out she could certainly argue
that she lacked the capacity to
understand what her conduct was and i
think that's one of the things they're
going to argue here that she had the
lack of understanding
all right we know the prosecution's
argument we'll see what the defense
brings here as well thank you both and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
you discuss justice in america
[Music]
you